la carrera para ser Primer Ministro
llega a su fin Richi zonas es elegido
como nuevo líder conservador y debería
llegar Este martes al número 10 de
Downey Street y proponer al Rey Carlos
III un nuevo gobierno gobierno
[Aplausos]
el Reino Unido es un gran país pero no
hay duda de que enfrentamos un profundo
desafío económico
nosotros ahora Necesitamos estabilidad y
unidad y mi prioridad va a ser mantener
nuestro partido y nuestro país Unido
Porque esa es la única forma en que
vamos a superar los desafíos que
enfrentamos y construir un futuro mejor
y más próspero para nuestros hijos y los
hijos de nuestros hijos
el paso al costado a la candidatura de
Penny morland le abrió un camino Express
para dirigir el país los diputados deben
saber que esta propuesta ha sido probada
de forma justa y exhaustiva por el
proceso acordado por el comité 1922 como
resultado ya hemos elegido nuestro
próximo Primer Ministro esta decisión
demuestra una vez más la diversidad y el
talento de nuestro partido rishi tiene
todo mi apoyo este domingo el favorito
Boris Johnson también decidió no
participar de la contienda por lo que se
redujeron los plazos para la elección
del nuevo líder Esta es la primera vez
que Reino Unido Escoge a una persona de
origen indio como dirigente pero este ex
banque multimillonario es para la vista
de los conservadores como el indicado
para dar tranquilidad a los mercados que
se han visto fuertemente golpeados tras
el paso y renuncia del issstrass como
primera ministra quien no supo conjurar
la crisis zonak recibió al país en medio
de una debacle económica postpandemia
con una inflación galopante escasa mano
de obra y de su unión entre los
conservadores